the latin american community not that
you can speak for the entire latin
american of course
but it it's very very interesting to me
that how
fervently democrat a lot of them are but
their belief
systems like all the way through and
through
hard work faith family you know like
that's you know this is not
exactly it's very simple it's very
simple
the land community only votes democrat
for one
reason and one reason only it's because
they want or they think that voting
democrat is going to get their
pancho to come over the border and get a
job here that's it
when you talk about the actual views
alignments
uh vision of the hispanic community has
it is the
opposite of the democrat party it is the
opposite of the democratic party but
all you have to do is grab one subject
for example with the black community you
grab one subject which is what is
what was that racism yeah with the
hispanics
immigration you got them the rest
they're blinded
voters it's a one-issue voter one issue
though
though um trump uh put the ncaap
on a 10-year on a 10-year plan obama had
it on a year to year funding
though he created the first step act
which released 4 000 prisoners
from non-violent offenses which 75 of
them were black
though the lowest unemployment for
hispanics and blacks were under trump
that's just facts people don't have to
agree facts don't care about your
feelings people i just hope you guys
understand that okay
these are facts right but yeah because
it's [ __ ]
yeah so what i'm getting at is that what
i'm getting at is that
but all you have to do is bring up
racism and you do that
boom everything else goes out the window
yeah but yeah
but so it's like yeah 99 of things one
but
and they'll literally vote for one
person the hispanic community does the
same thing
like i was having a conversation when
hillary clinton pulled out the hot sauce
and yeah
that's like that that didn't win no for
example like
and i'm gonna we're gonna move on right
now what what my word
that was i was ridiculous so so i'm i'm
i
love this i love my in-laws like to
death
right i shout out to my in-laws i love
them they are they are
like parents i never had right i love
them they're just the greatest people
they're just great people right and um
and they're very open to listening so i
when i go to their house i'm hammering
them and i'm like the tvs i'm like
that's [ __ ]
that's a lie that's [ __ ] like the
whole time the thing is
like i'm just throwing [ __ ] at the tv
the whole time i'm like you get some
points change the channel
right and so they believe me because
they trust me
still and i'm not against it i don't
want to be one of those i'm not against
it
i believe your body your choice after we
told them and i showed them all the
information
on not to get jabbed right
they still went to get jabbed and i said
why if i showed you everything
because the problem pat says this all
the time it's the last appointment of
the day
their last appointment of the day is
univision it's not me
so i can say whatever i want for seven
hours
the last two hours before they go to
sleep they're going to sleep with that
in mind so they want to get a job
it's like i just showed you all the
information blood calculations
pfizer's bringing you you have to
forgive me i don't watch a lot of
telemundo so is it
like it's it's it's i think i'm sure you
were killing me
i get my weather i get my weather from
television
it's spanish propaganda it's propaganda
so like for example jorge ramos's
daughter paola ramos
i think her name is paula you're nailing
all these again yeah
so so paula ramos if i'm mistaken um she
worked for the clinton campaign so then
you wonder
why you wonder why it's cnn it's spanish
and spanish cnn bro and so what i'm
getting at is that
even having a me in the family even
having a me
the tv has more power over there but
generationally the more men like you
come
in set down roots in the country you're
flipping them i'm gonna flip them so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you